ogni volta che iniziò a registrare una
puntata di sta roba che l'ho già fatto
due volte mi viene la pelle d'oca cielo
già bello a tutti i ragazzi pervenute
quest'anno video sono famiglie oggi
siamo su purtroppo su il segreto che
quel sito dove la gente scrive i segreti
cerchiamo segreti su fa vj dollari 14
anni ciao tesoro
una sera stavo vedendo un video di favi
j quando il video è finito vado in bagno
a fare la pipì e avevo le mutande
sporche di sangue fu la prima volta che
vive nel ciclo lorenzo se stai leggendo
questo segreto sappi che mi hai fatta
diventare donna o quasi la tentazione di
chiamare mia madre commosso spiegarle
che cosa è successo ma non lo farà
tornare 19 anni il mio segreto è che da
qualche mese
leggo fanfiction gay tra fa vj esterni e
spero che sia mina davvero anche se ne
vedono lo mostrerebbero posso venire a
ficcarsi la lingua in gola perfetto a
posto sono fidanzata con un ragazzo che
assomiglia veramente un botto afa vj
tantissimo veramente e l'altro giorno
guardando un video di lor e fave assieme
mi vide che gli mandai un bacino un po
nascosto certo guardi i miei video così
io non posso vederti se tu mi fai così
mentre coadiuvino quindi puoi anche non
farlo se da selena gomez a questa mi
avrebbe già denunciato per stalking
maturo anni mi chiese quindi stai
assieme a me solo perché gli assomiglio
io gli dissi di no ovviamente ragazze
aiuto non so come farà dirglielo dopo ho
paura che nessuno mi voglia e ci sta
motivo dove di 16 anni secondo me fa vj
e pieno di [ __ ] tutto qua
veroli vita
uomini uomini o di adesso arrivano a
superare finalmente poi ci divertiamo mi
sono reso conto che il suo canale di fa
vigili un canale morente riesco a
percepire anno la non voglia di lorenzo
di registrare i video in questo preciso
momento sto valutando se teese
iscrivermi dal suo canale youtube ma per
me è un suicidio è stato prima virtù
perché ho seguito mi ci sono affezionato
non so se è seria o meno però comunque
al momenti a una star o non è vero
poi magari non sai guardato un video in
un petit dei video in un periodo in cui
magari aveva una febbre che cazzo ne so
se fosse veramente così come dici tu
fare in menu vincerne non ne farei una
al giorno e soprattutto non non
giocherei alle stesse cose anzi se io
veramente mi rompe s'incazza fare video
vorrei sempre è prestato ai più dispiace
sempre invece ho cercato di non fare le
cose che non mi piacciono per divertirmi
di più giocando quindi mi dispiace che
tu creda questa cosa in realtà non ti
assicuro veramente che non è così
uova 19 anni sono fidanzato con il mio
ragazzo perché somiglia fa vj io starò
con lui finché non troverà il vero favi
e non lo farò innamorare di me mi
dispiace se ho già cliccato la lingua in
gola a set mi un po di tempo fa ho
sognato che incontravo fa vj e così a
random andiamo a fare la spesa
questa ragione non posso credere a
quello che sto per leggere perché ho
dato un'occhiata veloce le agghiaccianti
sono una donna di 42 anni e una figlia
di 13 lei è una grande fan di fa vj
questo ragazzo fa video su internet ed è
molto famoso tra i giovani io ho
iniziato a vedere dei video per caso per
sapere cosa ci trovasse mia figlia in
quel ragazzo non so come sia successo ma
quel ragazzo mia tratta da subito sono
fissate ormai quando faccio l'amore con
mio marito penso a frigerio e si fanno a
in molte aree di il porca vacca ho visto
fa vj che limonata con una sua fan stack
lì non è una mia fan o di a morte selena
gomez perdonami favi mata tranquilla se
sono un po [ __ ] la mia ragazza mi ama
per che assomiglio a fa vigenti è quello
di prima è il tipo della ragazza di
fermare che stavano lui so perché vabbè
uomo di 17 anni una volta incontrato fa
vj di persona il segreto non sono
riuscito a chiedergli di fare una foto
con me mi imbarazzava chiedetemi le foto
no problem
io sono qui per lo faccio per voi a
prescindere che questo video finisca o
meno sul suo canale improbabile dato
l'assente umorismo
ci tengo a far ciò per la famiglia che
speciale trasferimento nei sei vi do la
splendida persona che è
e quando sono triste parto con una
maratona dei suoi video mi aiuta
tantissimo grazie infinitamente spero di
poterti incontrare un giorno anche io ho
una mia coetanea mica 22 anni non si
legge mai solo adesso
da un anno a questa parte iniziato a
seguire fa vj ogni giorno aspetto con
felicità un sono video e lo ringrazio
perché li avete visti a primonumero il
mio segreto è che quel ragazzo mi ispira
troppo 7 pareva senso sfrenarsi sfrenato
e sfrenato e credo che se mai lo
incontrerò dal vivo di salterò addosso
come un gatto su un topolino selena non
ascoltare ok sono topolino bailey
sinceramente preferisco il tas in italia
di fa vj che occidentali scherma di
gabbana ben grazie al cazzo ogni tanto
mi capita di rimanere seduta successo
per un ora a guardare i video di farisei
dicono che aiuta un sacco sono un
soldato e più di tanta roba e ogni
giorno devo faticare per arrivare a fine
giornata
le uniche due cose che mi chiedono se di
volare sono
famiglia che mi supporta sempre comunque
è lorenzo studi fa vincere 1 youtuber
che seguo da poco è una persona
particolare che mi piace che mi
piacerebbe conoscere un giorno in quanto
abbiamo caratteri simili
sei un soldato ai vent'anni sposami
ragazzi sto cantando un po di masturbo
perché mica era cosa indecente barca il
mio segreto è che non riesco a non
guardare i video di famiglie mentre
faccia la cacca mi aiuta concentrarmi e
farla più veloce l'avevo detto io che
aiutava un sacco l'altro scorso anno e
rigida all'expo di milano con la mia
classe tutte le navi che erano molto
emozionate che forse potevamo incontrare
fa vj sapete cosa è successo abbiamo
incontrato fa vj era il giorno che
fortunato indimenticabile della mia vita
io non ci sono mai andato all'expo di
milano che avete incontrato non ero io
io non capisco come hai fatto ad avere
tutta questa fama fa vj per questa
parlando con me direttamente non con i
segreti sapeva che avrei letto il suo
messaggio non capisco come fate ad avere
tutta questa fama fa vigilia all'inizio
quando aprì un canale youtube è
difficile arrivare a tanti iscritti ma
tesi pure arrivato a un milione
faccio i video dove leggo che le fan si
masturbano sui miei video che meglio fa
un sacco di iscritti fai così un sacco
non ti stupire del fatto che sono
arrivato un milione anzi quasi 4 milioni
ma stupisci ti del fatto che c'è gente
che si tocca pensando a me ea stefano
che ci rimaniamo mi piacerebbe un sacco
che fa piacere leggere leggere leggere
le fan fiction su di lui tipo just sex o
lesson sono per avere l'associazione no
ragazzi miei io direi che possiamo
concludere qui perché ho letto o scelta
non finire ma quello lo sapevo già
ho tentato disperatamente di trovare
commenti che potessero essere oggetto di
discussione tra me e voi
alcuni li ho trovati grazie a dio quindi
non solo masturbazione e robe varie
voglio concludere lasciandovi il tempo
per leggere questo commento mentre io
fisso la webcam
direi che possiamo concludere qui
ragazzi però che mi sia piaciuto ragazzi
come solito giro invece al momento e mi
piace anche i vari social che il compito
di iscrizione il telecomando non c'è più
6 suicidato ma lo capisco perché non
puoi stare un ascolta sta roba per due
ore e pretendere di essere ancora
intatto se avete ischia neri ci
rimettiamo al prossimo video belle
ragazze
[Musica]